all right welcome to new video I'm
starting a five-minute game here only
thing I'm just seeing that I have all
sounds disabled and this irritates me i
need at least those clicks and the check
the checks all and so on so we've got an
English opening here symmetricom right
he goes 46cm this is very flexible let's
see what is doing is playing e6 ah ok a
pretty sure I know when playing him so
maybe even a teammate of mine so let's
see what happens here we have this very
solid set up for four blagghhhhh play b6
and so on yeah how should I continue you
can play for before so I go before but
he will have 90 form and this is fairly
solid for black I wonder if I maybe have
some some other idea
what about Quincy one maybe Quincy one
Bishop age 6 okay let's try this need to
be quick am I know is pretty fast player
if it's necessary so yeah the sound
prevents this visual page six idea maybe
I can provoke f6c I okay it doesn't do
it what about you form to block the
position and then maybe f4 mean if he
goes to d4 then I might have this f4
idea it's a thing not a very comfortable
position for white I mean black doesn't
have have anything special but so it's
not obvious how you should continue okay
this is surprising for me at least that
he's taking with porn but maybe it's an
idea going for f5 maybe at some point
maybe now even but this would be
weakening yeah okay let's think about
this should I exchange this bishop
really yeah i can drop it back to d2
still I'm not sure maybe it's good for
me to exchange one one one pair of
pieces here to have a little bit more
room in this position oh this is
interesting maybe he's going for be five
okay let's get the Queen out of the sea
file first okay I think I'll take this
chance to to play a five if he takes
Bishop h3 sell this wouldn't be good on
it takes it should be nice now unless
I'm overlooking something I'll get a
piece on f5 now and this bishop on p7 is
not not especially great yeah I like the
position now I'm pretty much down on the
clock but position wise i'm good i think
we should buy five would be the next
move p.m. right so still I should play
this so he might have some ideas b5
throughout the only counter play but
this isn't isn't really threatening much
question is what what will our play
after let's say Roxy seven should I just
double on the F file or maybe even move
the Bishop to e6 maybe wouldn't be bad
it wouldn't be easy to to get rid of the
bishop on the square maybe bishop see
aid yeah like the idea ok this may be a
good move so I should should try to
double on the FR he can move the night
now I take the bishop but ok he lets me
take at the end now I've got them this
pile up on the FR f five ok once play 55
hmm maybe G forms EG whole puzzle yeah
come on need to play croquet if it takes
with the Queen rubgy to win system so
now i can try to get them get this night
to to a five or h4 h5 maybe not quite
sure what's better this is a good move
trying to exchange Queens a damn i don't
know i don't i cannot really prevent it
alright so he will exchange queens now
lady doesn't need to do it himself I'm
not threatening much here maybe maybe
I'm threatening to move the Queen and
this end game after Queen exchange I
have some I just play against f6 but you
still has this b5 possibility but I can
always play be 30 what this black
resigned oh this was a sudden end here
just a blackout yeah I think black was
was doing fine here p.m. if it just
exchanges here I'm not sure I mean maybe
if I've got a little bit of something
but it's not like it looks looks
brilliant or the computer really gives
me you should want to share surprising I
mean huge advantage like 0.6 pawn but
0.6 or something tangible yeah maybe the
f6 point is really that week I mean I
like white white here even before I
looked at the computer evaluation but I
thought it would be quite ok so for
black yeah counterplay is hard to come
by here this P five I mean I can just
take it him a couple I be three of em
I'm lazy to calculate the bond grab and
it's not so easy to see how how the
counter counter play should come maybe
something like here here not fattening
does not age five so maybe here that all
night h5m you can cover not not great
but somehow you need to cover the spawn
now I can maybe press on yeah yeah white
is better I have have quite quite you to
try the gym I mean it's it's something
you really feel
position that white is better but it's
not like winning instantly or something
he's got the real big Wheaton weakness
he and the position so at the end of
this kind of stuff this year really got
got a problem at the end he could just
play on g5 keep it closed and then I
would try to switch my my play more to
the to the queenside maybe combining
this with H form and maybe it's about
equal yeah thanks for watching this game
it's a bit bit of a shame that it ended
so suddenly but what can you do yeah
thanks and talk to you soon in a new
video